FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm honored to
welcome back Chittra Banerjee
Divakaruni to Google.
Her accomplishments as an
author are far-reaching.
Her short story collection,
"Arranged Marriage," won an
American Book Award in 1995.
And two novels, "The Mistress
of Spices" and "Sister of My
Heart," were adapted into
film recently as well.
Her work's also been published
in over 50 magazines,
including "The Atlantic Monthly"
and "The New Yorker,"
and her writing has been
included in over 50
anthologies, including "Best
American Stories," "The
O'Henry Prize Stories," and
"The Pushcart Prize
Anthology." Her fan base is
global, with her work being
translated into 20 languages,
including Dutch, Hebrew,
Indonesian, and Japanese.
And apart from being a
celebrated author, she is
Professor of Creative Writing at
the University of Houston.
On a personal note, as a woman,
mother, daughter, and
friend with a strong interest
in the experience of the
Southeast Asian community,
I've been drawn
to Chittra's work.
Her books have become
favorites.
For me, her stories fully
immerse the reader in her
characters' journey, joys,
struggles, and triumphs.
Be it rallying for success or
sharing in the pain of a
troubled experience, her style
brings the reader deep into
the moments.
And at times, it feels like you
can see, taste, and hear
the sounds that are described
in the book.
She's been hailed by Abraham
Verghese as a gifted
storyteller, and by "People"
magazine as a skilled
cartographer of the
heart, and I
completely +1 this sentiment.
And I'm uberly excited to hear
experts from this latest work,
"Oleander Girl," and learned
recently over lunch that we
are very privileged to be the
first ones hearing this here
in Google, because this
is a pre-launch.
It's actually the first place
she's reading here in
California, and it's being
officially launched tomorrow.
So please join me in welcoming
Chittra Banerjee Divakaruni.
[APPLAUSE]
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI:
Thank you, Regina.
Thank you for inviting
me back to Google.
It is such a pleasure
to be here.
It's always exciting
and wonderful.
And I always say that if I were
a techie, this is where I
would want to work.
So I'm in the happy position of
actually having two books
that are coming out
at the same time.
I'll be talking about "Oleander
Girl," but I just
wanted to show everyone this
book, which is my first
children's picture book.
And it's called "Grandma and
the Great Gourd." And it is
the retailing of a Bengali folk
tale my grandfather used
to tell me when I was little and
I was growing up in India.
So it's very exciting for me to
share this book with other
people, people who speak English
and who might want to
share the culture with
their children.
And this is "Oleander Girl." You
heard that it's just come
out, so it's an exciting time.
It's kind of a scary time,
because you put your baby out
there in the world and you wait
to see what other people
are going to say.
And interestingly, this
too is a family story.
It is a story that talks about
a grandfather and a
granddaughter, among
other things.
This is a book--
a novel about love, not just
romantic, although that is
there, but really, human love.
And it's about difference.
It's about how to do we live
in the world, which is a
multicultural world, an
increasingly global world?
How do we live there with people
who believe differently
about things, who have different
ideologies or ways
of life or religions?
How can we live in friendship
and in love?
This book is set in 2002, which,
as I'm sure you know,
was an important year for--
in many places of the world.
In America, it was post-9/11.
We were really getting into
understanding what were the
long-term effects of 9/11, not
just on the families who had
lost people, but on Americans
overall, and especially
brown-skinned Americans who
looked quote unquote
different, who looked quote
unquote dangerous.
2002 is also the year of the
Gujarat riots in India,
terrible Hindu Muslim riots,
the repercussions of which
went all across the country to
Kolkata, which is the city
where the book is set in India,
which is also my city
where I was born and
spent many years.
Those are some of the things
that I tried to bring together
in "Oleander Girl." "Oleander
Girl" is also about the fast,
changing nature of
India itself.
Because in Kolkata, as I've
experienced it, and maybe some
of you have experienced it in
other places, the old and the
new clash up against
each other.
India is changing so fast,
and yet it has
such a strong tradition.
What happens when you push them
up against each other?
So this is the story of a
young woman from a very
traditional Indian family who
has been brought up by her
grandparents, and who falls in
love with a young man from a
very different kind of family.
Her fiance Rajat comes
from a new India.
Their family is new money.
And what happens when you try to
put those families together
is part of what the story or
"Oleander Girl" is about.
I'm going to read to you a
little bit from the beginning.
The story begins the night
before Korobi--
the main character--
her engagement ceremony.
As I said, she lives in a very
traditional household, in an
old, old mansion.
And there's a temple in
their family grounds.
That's where the engagement
ceremony will take place.
But this is the night before.
This part is in Korobi's
voice.
The book is told
in many voices.
As a writer, I'm always
interested in how the teller
of the story changes the tale.
So different parts will
be seen in the eyes
of different people.
This is Korobi's voice.
"I'm swimming through a long
underwater cavern flecked with
blue light--
the cavern of love, with
Rajat close behind me.
We're in a race, and
so far I'm winning,
because this is my dream.
Sometimes when I'm dreaming,
I don't know it.
But tonight, I do.
I smile and feel my
mouth filling
with cool silver bubbles.
Rajat's fingers brush the
backs of my knees.
Even in my dream, I know that
if I slow down just a bit,
he'll grab my waist and
pull me to him for
a mischievous kiss.
Imagining that kiss
sends a shudder of
pleasure through me.
Then, out of nowhere, a
wave breaks over me.
Salt and sand are
on my tongue.
I try to spit them out,
but they fill my
mouth, choking me.
Where is Rajat when
I need his help?
Gasping, I thrash about, and
wake in my bed, tangled in my
bed clothes.
As my eyes adjust to the
darkness, I know at once that
someone is in the room.
It's impossible.
I always lock the door before
going to sleep, and
the window is barred.
But there it is--
in the armchair in the corner
of the night room, a still
female form, black against the
darkness of the room, looking
towards me.
'Mother?' I whisper, my fear
replaced by yearning that's as
old and as illogical as anything
I can remember.
I know so little about my
mother, only that she died 18
years ago, giving birth to me,
a few months after my father,
an ambitious law student, had
passed away in a car accident.
Perhaps she died of
a broken heart.
I never knew for sure,
because no one would
speak to me of them.
My grandfathers had to put aside
their own broken hearts
to care for me, and
I'm grateful.
They did it well.
Still, all through my years
growing up, I longed for a
visitation from my mother.
Now, years after I had armored
my heart and accepted that my
mother was gone from my
life, here she is.
How can I be sure it is her?
There are some things we know,
in our breath, in our bones."
So Korobi begins to think about
why her mother might
have come to see her
on this night.
And she figures it's because her
life is about to change.
She's about to get engaged.
She's entering adulthood.
She's going to become part
of a different family.
Maybe her mother is concerned
and wants to know if she's
going to be all right.
So she began to reassuring
her mother.
She begins telling her about
Rajat, what a wonderful man he
is, how much she loves him,
how much he loves her.
But when she finishes speaking,
she feels something
is not quite right.
"I'm breathless from my
confession, but still the air
in the room hangs uncertain,
incomplete.
My mother continues to
look out the window.
Why will she not speak to me?
Where is the blessing kiss I've
wanted all my life, cool
as a dew-drenched breeze
on my forehead?
Suddenly, the window behind
her is filled with light.
Outside, I see an ocean over
which a sun is setting.
Have I fallen, then, from
one dream into another?
She points over the ocean,
leaning toward it with such
sad longing that sorrow
twists my heart.
I understand.
She hasn't come to
learn about me.
All the things I said to her,
she probably knew them
already, being dead.
She has appeared now, instead,
to tell me something.
But what?
Talk to me, mother.
This time when she turns to
me, I notice that my dream
mother has no mouth.
Her frame shivers with effort,
as though she longs to speak.
She begins to dissolve.
I can glimpse the ocean through
her tattered body,
waves breaking apart on rocks.
An urgent sorrow radiates from
her disappearing form.
Then she's gone, and I'm finally
awake, blinking in the
first rays of the sun entering
the room through the bars."
So Korubi is really concerned,
and she wants to understand
what this means.
And she decides that even though
her grandparents don't
like to talk about her mother,
she's got to ask her
grandmother about this
night visit.
And I'll read to you
what happens.
So this is after the engagement
ceremony, and her
grandmother has just cleared up
everything and said, go lie
down, because that's going to be
a big party in the evening
and you should rest.
" 'Grandma, wait.
I've got to talk to you.' I
blurt out the words because
there's no good way
to say them.
'Someone was in my
room last night.
I think it was my mother.'
I wait for grandmother to
dismiss my foolish notions
with a laugh and send me
off, but she pales and
takes a step back.
The crystal dish falls from
her hand and shatters.
Tiny silver balls go flying
over the veranda.
'Why do you think that?'
she whispers.
'I felt it.'
Even to my ears, my answer
sounds weak.
But grandmother accepts it.
Her hands are trembling.
'Did it--
did she say anything to you?' I
shake my head, disconcerted.
I had no idea that my pragmatic
grandmother believed
so strongly in ghosts.
But even if she did, why would
the thought of her dead
daughter's spirit agitate
her like this?
I realize I don't want
to know the answer.
'Maybe I imagined it,' I say.
'Maybe you did,' grandmother
says, but without conviction.
'I'll go lie down now.' 'You
do that,' she says.
'You rest too.' 'Yes,'
she says.
But when I look back from the
doorway, she's still standing
among the broken glass,
scattered cardamom seeds
surrounding her like a field
of frozen tears."
So that's the beginning of
"Oleander Girl." And now
things are going to change very
rapidly in Korobi's life,
because her grandfather, whom
she loves dearly, is going to
die all of a sudden
of a heart attack.
And when he dies, she will
realize that he's kept a
secret from her all her life.
And this secret will
change her whole
notion of who she is.
It will shake up her
sense of identity.
And she's going to have to put
off her wedding and come to
America on a search.
And what she discovers is part
of the story of "Oleander
Girl."
But "Oleander Girl" is not
just Korobi's story.
It's also the story of Rajat,
who is left behind.
And this is kind of a turning
around of the hero's journey,
which is a mythic theme that
I used for this book.
Because generally in the hero's
journey, the man goes
off to war or to adventure, and
the woman is the one who's
left behind.
Well, in this case, Rajat is
going to be left behind,
although he will have
its own adventures.
Because right around this
time is when the
Gujarat riots happen.
And as I said, the repercussions
will be felt all
the way across the country,
and especially in Rajat's
family's warehouse,
where Hindus and
Muslims work together.
A lot of times when I'm writing
a story, people ask
me, where do the story
ideas come from?
Is it something out
of your own life?
And with my previous book,
which also I came here to
Google to present, one amazing
thing, there was an actual
occurrence when we were being
evacuated from Houston, where
I live, because a huge
hurricane was coming.
And we were stuck on the freeway
in this massive,
massive traffic jam.
The hurricane was coming
right at us.
And all of us strangers in a
life-threatening situation
began to panic.
And that's really what give me
the idea for one amazing thing
where something similar
happens.
But with this one, I really
wasn't sure of any one thing
in my life.
It was just ideas, thoughts,
things that I felt strongly
about that went into
this book.
But as I wrote it, I
realized something.
Because a lot of times, our
writing comes out of our
subconscious, and we don't
even know until we finish
writing it where it came from.
And as I was writing this book,
almost towards the end,
I realized in some ways, this
is really my take on my own
family's story.
Not that exactly the same things
happened, but I too,
when I was in college, I
realized that my family had a
secret that they had
kept from me.
And that had involved my
grandfather, and it had
involved the fact that long
before I was born, he
disinherited one of my uncles.
And I won't go into that story,
but somewhere in my
mind, in my heart, where I
really loved my grandfather
very much, this had created
a major conflict.
How could the man that I loved
so much have done something
like that to his own son?
And I could never
understand it.
But I think this book allowed
me to explore that, although
the actual secret here and what
the grandfather has done
is different.
But it was also a secret.
And it was something that when
Korobi finds out, she is
devastated that her grandfather
could do something
like this and keep this
secret from her.
And so I think one of the things
that's at the heart of
this book is, what do you do
when people that you love
dearly, you discover something
about them that you can't
agree with, and you can't
come to terms with?
It's also about how family
secrets are often--
they really reflect on the
culture around them.
What is considered shameful?
What is considered not
OK for the family?
What has to be kept hidden?
And what is the result of that
which we keep hidden from
people when they find
out about it?
So anyway, that's a little bit
about "Oleander Girl." And if
you have questions, of course
I'd be very happy to answer
them, especially if they're
easy questions.
And as you're thinking of
questions, I'm going to say
one more thing, which is, I
just want to tell you, you
probably hear this from authors
all the time, but
Google has improved
my life so much.
It has had such a positive
influence on my research.
It has just made a world
of difference.
I really want to thank
Google for that.
I can just find things out just
like this through Google.
So thank you.
The question, which is, have I
ever been sad to say goodbye
to a character?
Have I ever brought
anyone back?
Well, you know, you mentioned in
the introduction "Sister of
My Heart," which has gone
on to become a film.
And that was the one book where
at the end of the book--
the book is about two cousins,
Sudha and Anju.
They're very close, and they
go through a lot of life's
tribulations together.
They help each other.
They're also in a conflict
sometimes.
But at the end of "Sister of
My Heart," I kind of knew
their story wasn't done,
somewhere deep down.
Because in the beginning of the
book, they're in India,
then they're separated through
their weddings and their
marriages, and then they come
together in America.
And at first, I'd thought
that that was the end.
That was the arc of their
friendship and their closeness
to each other.
But then as time went along,
I knew they had a whole new
story, an immigrant story in
America, where now, because
they were in a different
place, their
relationship was different.
Because sometimes that's what
happens through immigration.
Your relationship with people
around you changes.
Your notion of yourself
changes.
So that's the one they came
back in a different novel,
"The Vine of Desire." And every
once in a while, I think
maybe they'll come back
one more time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming to Google.
I'm really excited
to read the book.
I have a question about
film adaptations.
So I've watched "Mistress of
Spices." I haven't watched the
other adaptations.
How involved are
you with them?
Do you have to go?
Do you feel like you still
have ownership over the
content and get mad at them?
How does that work?
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI:
That's a great question.
The question is about film
adaptations about my book.
And now I've had a "Mistress of
Spices" made into a film,
"Sister of My Heart," a short
story from "Arranged Marriage"
entitled "The Word Love"
that was made
into a bilingual film--
English and Bengali--
called "Amar Ma," and actually
won some awards at Cannes.
And right now, one
amazing thing has
been optioned by Hollywood.
And they finished writing the
screenplay, so we're kind of
excited to see what the
next step will be.
Well, a short answer to what
control do I have?
Like, none.
[LAUGHTER]
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI: And
actually, I don't really
want control.
Because it would be like if I
were trying to write a book
and someone was telling
me what to do.
So if I am trying to tell the
director what they should do
with the book, that's really
interfering with their
artistic freedom.
So I'm perfectly OK with-- if
I like the director, I'm
perfectly OK with letting
them have their vision.
And I realized with "Mistress of
Spices," when I was reading
the screenplay that
was made by a
wonderful producing company--
Gurinder Chadha, who made "Bend
it for Beckham," and her
husband Paul Berges--
and they had showed it--
I was very involved, as in they
would show me everything
as they were doing it.
They would call me and
ask me questions.
They came and stayed out here
in California with me for a
while they were discussing the
project and getting a vision.
So I was very involved
that way.
And I could see that they were
moving away from the book.
The romantic story, which is
part of the book, was becoming
really important.
And I could see why, because
they've already picked the
heroine, Aishwarya Rai, who has,
as you know-- who's been
called the most beautiful
woman in the world.
And they wanted the
camera on her.
And I think they did a great
job, and lots of people really
loved the movie.
I loved many parts
of the movie.
It's different from the book,
because the book is kind of an
immigrant story.
It's the stories of all the
people who come to the store
where the mistress of spices
lives and works, and she helps
them by giving them spices.
So that part became smaller, and
the romantic part became
larger in the movie.
And I realized that--
that's when I realized the
movie is their work.
The book is my work.
And it's perfectly all right.
And I think the wonderful thing
that does happen with
the movie, is a lot of people
will see the movie, then
they'll come back and
read the book.
And if they love the movie,
that's great.
They'll come and
read the book.
And if they read the book and
they like the book better, am
I going to complain?
So I'm excited to see what will
happen with "One Amazing
Thing." They're hoping to make
it a joint venture between
Hollywood and India.
So they're looking for
people on both sides.
And they're looking for some
money, so, you know, all you
Google people, if you have money
and you don't know what
to do with it, come
see me afterwards.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned in the
book that it's told partly
from Korobi's viewpoint,
and then later
from Rajat's viewpoint.
Did you have any trouble
switching between the two, as
in like a male versus
female voice?
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI:
That's a good question too.
The question is about
the different
viewpoints in the book.
I read to you the part in
Korobi's voice, which is in
first person.
And the question is, did I
have trouble switching?
It takes me a while
to get the voice.
And then once I figured out the
voice, in the later parts
of the novel, I won't have
trouble switching.
But in the early part,
I would have to try
like several times.
The thing about this book
is, it's in first
person and third person.
So Korobi gets the first person,
where she's saying I
feel this, I think this.
But the other parts--
Rajat's voice, Korobi's
grandmother Sarojini's voice--
they're all third person.
So it's what they're thinking
and what they're feeling, so
this a little more distance.
There's a little more chance
for the reader to come and
interpret what's happening.
So that was the difference.
And one of the voices that I
became really fond of, and
that kind of surprised me as
the novel went along, is
Rajat's family chauffeur
Asif's voice.
And he became really important
in the story.
And he brings in a different
religious angle,
because he's Muslim.
And he struggles, especially
when the Gujarat riots are
going on, with the idea
that he's a Muslim.
He's working for a Hindu.
And he has some trouble with
that idea when all of this
interracial violence,
inter-religious
violence is going on.
So that was an interesting voice
that I had to really
work at, but then I became very
happy about that voice.
But that's a great question.
I think part of your question
is, is it harder to write the
male voice than the
female voice?
For me, it is.
I have to work much harder
at the male voice.
The female voice just comes
naturally to me.
But with the male voice, I
have to think about it.
I have to listen to it.
Fortunately in my home, I have
lots of opportunity, because
my home is made up of my husband
and my two sons.
So it's all male voices.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming today.
I wanted to ask who some of your
favorite authors are, and
maybe if there are any authors
who have inspired
you, who are they?
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI:
Yes.
Who are some of my favorite
authors who have inspired me?
Truly, I have been inspired by
so many authors, because I
came to writing late.
And I had already finished
all my formal education.
I was already working by the
time I started writing.
And so most of what I
learned were from
books, were from authors.
And I've been particularly
influenced by multicultural
contemporary women's voices.
So one of the writers that I
love and I really need to
quite often is Toni Morrison.
And just, I love the way she's
taken the African-American
experience and she's just made
it available to everyone
without diluting it.
That's something I
really aim for.
I want to create the Indian or
Indian-American experience.
I want to invite other people
into it, but I don't
want to dilute it.
I want to make it the
way it is, real.
And so her and Maxine Hong
Kingston, a Bay Area writer
who writes wonderfully about
the Chinese-American
experience.
She has a book called "The Woman
Warrior" that I read
when I was in college when
I was going to Berkeley.
And I think that book really
changed my life, and it made
me see my own immigration
experience differently.
And it also made me think that
yes, it's possible for me to
write the stories of the people
that I see around me,
that a large immigration story
of which I too am a part.
So those are two that I love.
And for the men sitting
in this audience,
I do read men authors.
One of the Indian authors that
I love is Amitav Ghosh.
I think he is just such
a fine writer.
I've learned a lot from
reading his books.
And a Caucasian author that
I have loved a lot is Tim
O'Brien, who has a wonderful
collection of
stories, Vietnam stories.
And I just love, love, love,
love those stories.
AUDIENCE: I'm always curious
about where writers go to put
together their creative
process.
Like, is there--
do you feel as though you need
to take yourself away from
your day-to-day and take
time to go somewhere?
Or do you find that the magic
of what's happening in the
household actually
helps contribute?
How is it for you when you're
writing a new book?
CHITTRA BANERJEE DIVAKARUNI:
Well, that's also a great
question, Regina.
Because as a mother, especially
when my children
were young, mothers who are
writers don't have that option
of going away.
You have to do your writing
right in the middle of
everything.
So I would do my writing when my
children took naps, or when
they went to nursery school,
or later when they went to
regular school.
Those were my writing hours.
And pretty much, all I needed
was a quiet space.
I needed a quiet space where
I would not be disturbed.
But more than that, really,
I couldn't hope for.
Because my family was there
and my family was
important to me--
so a quiet space.
I had to organize my schedule
as intelligently as I could,
so maybe I would write late in
the night or when the children
were at school.
And that's how I did it.
In fact, I think if I went away
somewhere, I would be so
distracted by--
people sometimes say, don't you
need to go do a beautiful
space to write?
And I'm like, no.
In my study, I face a blank
wall, and that's how I write
best, because I'm not distracted
by anything.
Thank you all so much.
It's so wonderful to
come to Google.
And really, thank you for taking
time out of your busy
days to come.
Enjoy the book.
[APPLAUSE]